hello welcome to the
uh journey the medical cosmos patreon
live stream it's hank
and matt and jim and james and devoki
hello how are all of you doing um
matt matt do you wanna do you want to
tell us why we've gathered here today
yes uh because you've already
accidentally misspoken so i will correct
that what did i do
another thing you said okay okay yeah
well all of them are patreon live
streams because where would we be
without them
yeah it's a good cover uh
so yes it is it's not a patreon
exclusive live stream
uh is uh there on the youtube channel
right now
uh thank you everyone who's watching
right now uh but yeah we are here
kind of just to hang out answer some
questions and look at some microbes but
we're also here as sort of a celebratory
thing because we recently hit
uh our two year anniversary on the
channel and also
our 100th video which makes sense when
you're doing weekly videos that those
two things are
close together yep but uh yeah both of
those things are very exciting
indeed thank you and also we've got two
microbes over here
uh james is as we speak controlling this
the view of these
uh which we can tell us a little bit
about
what what are we looking at uh so these
are some
predatory single cell organisms called
the leptus
and we are watching them just
uh eat something at the moment it's just
eating now
actually like okay there
yeah so yeah they're just minding their
own business
and they don't care about us so they're
just
enjoying so is the tail the front end
yeah the tail yeah
yeah it's called the proboscis it's a
really cool name
actually yeah it's eating another thing
yeah it's just gone
so yeah it's that that proboscis is
armed with uh many toxin ejecting
uh extrusions so when they touch
something
uh these things are just getting fired
and they're just killing the
prey and then uh there's uh there's a
mouth
right under that um that elephant thingy
yeah and then there yeah it does it
looks like an elephant
uh it even has like a little
elephant-like eye sort of situation
going on that's i assume just a vacuole
or
something but yeah yeah it's it's a
footwork hill it's
what it just ate yeah it's whatever i
just ate
okay well it looks like they got plenty
to eat
uh and i i guess there's a bunch of them
on there
is this is this a uh colony that you
have uh are growing and keeping alive
and healthy
so yeah last last week i collected some
samples from
like city fountain and they were there
and
then i'm just trying to set a culture
because um
like at the moment i have couple of
projects with many different
microorganisms and i'm trying to culture
them in my bathroom
and because that's the coolest and uh
you know
most suitable place for microbes let's
say
and i'm so sorry my cats started to zoom
just right now
and yeah
so so i have many of them
and um one interesting thing about them
actually
you're just gonna see it now yeah so
they recognize each other which is
something really fascinating they are
not
harming each other it's like you know
otherwise
they would just kill themselves
accidentally every time their
like proboscis touches their body it
just it would just
you know sorry i keep track of them
yeah uh yeah and
so they're recognizing each other and
which is something absolutely amazing
and we don't know
yeah jellyfish work this way too and
we're not sure how they do
it like jellyfish you know like the the
way that the
pneumatocysts work is that they just
fire upon mechanical stimulation
and so they will sting anything they
touch except themselves and other
jellyfish and yeah how do they know we
don't know
which is pretty freaking cool i wanted
to jump in just to say that we should
introduce ourselves
that was my initial plan but then i got
distracted by
understandable yeah we need to say
like who we are real quick and just what
we do here on the channel
so uh hank you want to start sure hello
i'm hangry and this is how this is what
i do
as a part of the channel and i
originally also
uh created the channel to have it be a
thing
but mostly now i just talk it to the
microphone um
james and i met a while ago because i
loved his youtube videos and when we
decided to make a youtube channel
together and
put together this little theme so that's
what i do
james do you wanna go next uh yeah sure
so i'm
i'm the guy behind the microscope i just
do microscopy
all day every day for i think four years
right now
and we are doing this show for two years
and yeah i go out collect samples every
day and
i come home then record some videos
and we come up with some episode ideas
and we make some cool
things for you to watch yeah
you also uh recently i have it right
here released a book
oh yeah the hidden beauty of the
microscopic world
which is very cool yes so everyone
should check that out as well
uh devoki what do you do um
mostly i write for the show so the words
that happen um
that hank says i will i will write them
um and then now i also
sometimes host the show um i don't have
my microphone with me so i can't do my
my impression of posting um but
that is my other new uh newer role on
the show
nice and matt how are you i'm
matt i am a producer slash uh editor
uh on the channel who edits all the
videos that you see and watch and then
also
works with these people behind the
scenes to make sure that we all
you know get stuff done and uh yeah that
we all
do our jobs yeah behind the deadlines
yeah um i'm and i never miss a deadline
everyone knows that about me
never creating huge problems for
everyone else
uh i almost recorded uh my my audio for
our next not our next episode but the
next one that hasn't been recorded yet
um yesterday but then my son was having
too much fun outside and i listened back
to the audio and i was like you can hear
the screaming yeah
i think a child screaming isn't
necessarily the relaxing background
noise
that people are used to on the channel
but it is the actual sound that microbes
make
yeah yeah yeah being close enough
[Music]
that's how they know not to to fire upon
each other
you hear them
if i was seeing you know the leptos just
coming towards me i would
be screaming as well oh i would totally
scream that's a
like if like if i was the size of one of
those guys that's getting eaten right
now
who are those who is getting eaten right
now james um
i don't remember their most recent name
but they're they're
algae called uh molasses
i have no idea how to pronounce it but
yeah they're um they're algae without
the chloroplast
so they are just hanging out there and
they reproduce super fast so
many many organisms they just feed on
them
and yeah but they there should be some
bigger things here
and so i want to show some
teleport hunting something bigger
so i'm sorry if i'm giving you guys
motion sickness right now
i'm just going through the slide
which is a really big slide how easy is
it for you to remember
like if you're like going all around a
slide how is it easy is it to remember
like if you saw something and you want
to go back to it
like that that depends so this slide i
prepared this like two days ago so there
are some
um um
biofilm growing so there are like some
landmarks
let's say like there's like you know
there's no street name but there's like
for example this thing
i don't know what's this this is just
like some
like some bacteria some debris something
you know
so i know where's this thing
just located and it just
so if i see something interesting here
like half an hour later i just come back
here look for this thing
and check around but um
also they are moving quite often
so yeah so it's like you just need to go
through everything
super fast with your lowest
magnification which is
um 50x right now
so we can just like it takes a couple of
minutes to go through the whole slide
um but one there's one important trick
actually
because when you're interested in this
the leptus
there's something really rare just
happening on the other side of the slide
so that's the risk that you have to take
when you're just recording this thing so
my my
biggest distractions
uh are diatoms so they are just
because i love them so much they look so
beautiful
so i'm just seeing something super rare
you know one of a kind
and then i'm just like trying to
take a look at the slide and see if
there's something
else and then i'm just getting
distracted with a diatom and
you know at the end of the day i have
like eight hours of diatom footage and
like eight minutes of this rare thing
and i'm like uh
my fiance knows it and i'm like why
didn't i record this for
you know for longer it's just i have
like just 20 seconds of it
and yeah and i have like hours of
diaphragm
they're footage beautiful you know what
like yeah what can i do it just
distracted me yeah we have some uh
questions coming in from the chat and
from patreon and a bunch of places
uh that i wanted to get to um one that i
feel like is just
uh some of these we can knock out a
little faster than others uh
somebody asked how uh we decide on the
topics to make videos on
is it just what pops up is it something
that we like plan out long term
and i will start with the short version
which is both
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure
um yeah i know for me it's at least like
usually talking with
uh james and devoki pretty regularly
about like
what do we want to make videos about and
also what can we make videos about
because obviously
people will ask us to make videos about
certain things and it just is
not possible we like to make videos that
we can first hand like get the footage
of
and there's just some things that james
doesn't have access to or that our
microscope won't allow us to see because
they're itty bitty
um and so yeah i think it's a little bit
of both i don't know if uh
james and devoki or hank have any more
thoughts on that but yeah i mean
sometimes we will have
like we have a number of ideas that
we've been sort of sitting around for a
long time
um that we we haven't been able to get
the right angle
on or we don't have the right footage
for it or something like that um
but the uh you know you usually will
have an idea and within
i don't know within a month that thing
will exist
does that sound right to bookie yeah
yeah i think especially
like we start out with like oh we have
this like beautiful footage
what's like the story that we can tell
and sometimes that's where
it's like we will talk in the meetings
and then i'll like go in and do the
research and see if there's anything
else we can kind of
expand on um and figure out from there
like what's going to be because there's
there's both like the big picture topic
of like oh we're going to talk about
this micro but then we have to like
actually pick
something to talk about with the micro
like topics are actually much more
specific than just
everything about the micro so that's
where a lot of it helps to like talk it
out with each other and see like what's
the thing that we're finding most
interesting
um what's kind of the thing that gives
us the most to talk about that we can
even maybe show with the video and
that's kind of where a lot of the
the fun challenges
yeah and something else uh sort of along
those lines i think it ties in
uh to when we were talking about like
the the timeline there of like you're
taking about like a month from idea
to script and at this point we're also
about a point like where it's the script
is done
about a month before the videos on the
channel so it's kind of like from idea
for a video to being live on the channel
is about two months at this point
um which is a nice little cushion um but
it also i think
uh somebody else asked in the chat uh
how do we all work together with like
different communication and learning
styles which obviously is a
huge question that we can spend the
entire hour talking about but i think
one thing that has helped our small team
is communicating about
like what kind of schedules work for
each person
uh and so like some of us work week to
week on deadlines some of us work every
two weeks some of us work like every
four weeks
turning in stuff and so it like finding
what works best for each person and then
how those
different deadlines come together to
like make the channel work properly
which is like uh i think worked out
really well for
all of us to sort of be able to work on
our own schedules while still coming
together to make
a video every single week and we don't
and again that is the person who has
figured that out for us
yeah yeah we're now now at the point
where we do not
too often end up in a situation where we
don't have something to put on the
channel
um on the day when we're supposed to
yeah that doesn't happen and that is
literally staring at staring at a
calendar
and if one little thing changes me going
like okay hold on
i'll get back to you in an hour with an
answer of how this will work
but it usually works out
cool i guess a question for you james
somebody asked um
basically uh charles underwood on
patreon asked
are you ever concerned about like more
harmful microbes
and how do you take precautions to not
get sick while you're collecting your
samples
honestly no because like every time i go
out for sampling especially in
you know in the summer it's like there's
some kids just swimming
where i collect myself
chances of me getting something um
dangerous
you know it's really really low
while i'm just working on you know like
just on slides and stuff so
um so if i have cuts or something
i try not to collect samples like
without you know without um
without gloves or something but
usually i'm not concerned about it and
a couple of weeks ago i collected some
samples and um there were this
um parasites that
can cause the swimmer's itch stuff so
and they were like
a bunch of kids were just jumping into
the
pump you know like from where i collect
the sample and they were like
looking at me like i'm just a crazy guy
but
i was looking at them in the same way
because they were sitting there
and yeah so yeah i actually
i got swimmer's itch uh recently and
i can see it on my arm still i don't
know that you can
i had i had a bunch of freaking itchy
bumps
because i got parasitic flatworms in my
skin
but they die in there so that's great
that you don't they don't like breathe
inside of you
so that's the good news do you ever see
anything else that's like
like a human pathogen do you see like
giardia parasites or anything where
you're like
ah look at that like i i think i saw
some giardia but it's like
um i think it's hard to be sure
without any other you know like staining
or
um like more like molecular work or
something but
um like rather than our single cell
eukaryote friends i'm worried about the
bacteria
you know because also the viruses so
it's just like
you might not die in the end but you
might get like a couple of
days really sick with stomach ache and
yeah right so well and like most most of
these microbes look like if i ate a
stenter or a tardigrade like that's
it's just a very small amount of food
for me
they're not dangerous i'm not gonna like
breed inside of me
yeah they hit the stomach acid and
that's sort of it for them yeah
yeah yeah actually i'm i'm going to be
working on
this i'm going to be trying to
make some um like
some alternative food sources
from from protests uh so you're gonna
are we gonna are you gonna send it to me
do i get to have a
slice a taste test i'm gonna send you a
standard pancake you know
you can you can make bacon pancakes and
you can just take
a song from jack the dog
oh man i i yeah it feels
weird now like i know it's a thing but
like picturing like we're looking at
these
like centers and everything like this on
our channel all the time and then just
going like
hump numbing down on a big old patty of
them
yeah i mean it feels very wrong to uh
like one of the things that we've
thought about doing is
since stenters can heal so easily to
on camera cut a center and let it like
heal itself
but it feels very wrong to do it while
you're sort of watching whereas on the
other hand
turning it into turning like 80 million
centers into a pancake
and eating that does not for some reason
bother me as much
[Laughter]
i want to jump in real quick just to do
the quick little like promo stuff we
should probably
do while we have a captive audience
one uh new exciting thing that just
launched on monday is our brand new
t-shirt
it's our tardigrade t-shirt um which is
uh
very cool uh designed by an artist
friend of mine mercedes tavish
there's a d a dark teal color and an ash
color which is like a light gray
and basically the idea is that we're
doing a pre-order for the entire month
like the end of july here and the whole
month of august
at the end of august whichever one sold
the most will continue to be in our
store on dftba.com
and the other one will go away forever
and i will just say looking at the early
numbers
uh if you wanna ash one you should get
it now
because holy cow is teal
kicking its butt
[Laughter]
we got the inside scoop on it everybody
whoa
what is that somebody asked one of the
questions let me see if i can find it
because i think that
uh as somebody david g asks what is the
smallest mushroom and what
does mycelium look like um so i don't
know if
if that if this we are about to answer
any of those questions and also that
appears to be moving right now which is
wild what are we looking at yeah uh this
is a foraminifera
so these are um
um giant marine single cell organisms
no but they can they can be a couple of
centimeters couple of inches
that's so there you know
yeah and uh they're amoeboid
organisms so they have this um
false feet pseudopodia
i can yeah can can you see it's like
like
just a second
[Music]
you're yeah the microscope is a little
behind the audio yeah yeah
yeah it's like 15 seconds yeah yeah
i thought that the i thought that the uh
i thought that that might be a mold with
with mycelium sticking on it because
that's kind of what my celium looks like
well don't worry everyone because uh
right now deboki is in the process of
working on a script
about fungus molds and spores uh so
actually our season five uh opener which
will be august
30th will feature mycelium all right
we'll get into more detail but that so
that is
that is a single cell like just like
long strands of a single cell right
there that's freaking
wild yeah and uh let me show it in
a little over magnification let's
set everything up
not cause a problem
oh hello
that's a giant now
[Laughter]
okay let me do some magic here
digital zoom okay
we're getting there sorry everybody
well the video is catching up i'm going
to
get a for sale from here
oh my god i have to jump on the tables
so so these are for a minifera two
i have some fossils yeah so they are
around for like
i don't know millions of years
i'm not sure if you can say anything but
yeah yeah
and they made it because
and are they so do they do they build
their shells
like do they mineralize their own shells
or do they like find stuff and aggregate
it
uh it depends on the it depends on the
for a minifera but
um this one it should be calcium
carbonate
the shell and it has this little
um rooms you can you can see them they
they look like
uh ammonites the the
this is yeah so we're more familiar with
that one so but um there's some deep sea
for a minifera which uh at least at
least there's one species with
um opal shell
which is something really interesting
[Music]
can you see those see the podium moving
yeah yeah and are those just out there
collecting food
yeah yeah so we just extend these things
and then just pull them back
with you know whatever stuck on them
mostly bacteria but they sometimes eat
diatoms
even some other like organisms like
stentors not really standards because
these are marine organisms centers are
freshwater but um
yeah they can they can eat big things as
well
cool uh i want to jump in with some more
of uh the questions we've been getting
uh one that i think uh here is for
devoki might not be easy to answer
but i did want to ask it uh here from
the patron of ours
uh basically says um
you've written a lot of very poignant
lines in the microcosmos videos
um and that they say brings tears to
their eyes
how do you come up with them and do you
have a favorite
[Laughter]
they usually really nice question yeah
that's really nice thank you very much i
very much appreciate that um
feels good to know i make people cry i
guess
usually something will occur like
sometimes some of those
i mean i don't know if what i think of
this poignant when i'm writing it is
always what other people think of this
poignant but sometimes there are some
sentences that kind of occur to you
where you're like oh this is something
um like that is both something that i
like the way it sounds but it gets to
like kind of an idea that i'm trying to
express and so like it helps me kind of
structure
um what i'm gonna write overall but
usually yeah it's just kind of a
something occurs to you and then i think
the other thing is
uh a lot of lines i write with a lot of
fear that like i'm over
doing it but i think because of the way
we're structured we're really lucky
where
uh both like matt and james will look
over it and like see if i'm like
not explaining anything correctly or
anything like that and then also
hank like will do his own round of
editing while recording so it's like a
very
it feels like a nice way to be able to
just kind of try whatever you want with
writing because you know
other people are gonna um look at it and
they're sort of like a collaborative
club collaborative um aspect to it even
if we're not always in the same room
together when we're
collaborating yeah so so
uh the that that sort of
allows for a greater risk taking if
you'd be like you normally wouldn't
think like ah because that's one of the
things about
about um you know more
expressive language is that it does feel
riskier
and like you could you could be people
might you might think like oh it's
people i think this is cringy
or are they gonna if it's like two over
the top or but to have it go through
some rounds where you can sort of take
the risk and then if
somebody along the way is like maybe we
should pull it back then it's like
okay but like yep but let's try let's go
for it
um and a lot of times in in online video
writing you don't get a lot of chance to
do that
to to make those statements so this
channel was nice for that reason
yeah yeah i think we've set a nice tone
that it fits in
very nicely already yeah
also i think the you know the topic is
something that gives people some
existential meaning you know it's so
it's really
really nice to write about
i hope that how you guys feel like oh
yeah
yeah i think that's a lot of the fun of
working on the shows it's not just like
being like oh this
is what microbes do it's like oh like
what is the other like
thing that they make you think about
because they are kind of weird and
that's part of the fun of them
so was this forum on the same slide as
those other things
were do you switch out a slide without
us noticing oh i i i
switched it do you want me to get back
to the no i just
didn't think that they those things
lived in the same environment
no no no there like i i have four slides
in front of me
so i'm just quickly switching between
them
so like trying to give the least
motion sickness or viewers
uh yeah uh james there's a question for
you uh about like
microbe hunting here uh on uh tyler
from our patreon asked uh i've been
hunting
for water bears for ages and can't find
them i've been picking moss off of trees
in my local forest
and still can't find them anything i
should look for in particular when
searching for tardigrades
um they're definitely there so i
recommend
him to check the like collect the moss
first
then soak it in the water and then shake
it in the water
and because water bears they don't
actually swim
they they just walk in the water so they
sink to the bottom of the dish you have
so
try to collect that sediment and there
they will be there and if you cannot
find them just
try different places but they're pretty
common
and like i collect them just
from the tree just right in front of my
house so
like after after rain i just go out with
a syringe
and i just suck some water and then come
home and i have like
yeah like tens of tardigrades
but uh
just keep sampling it's like um
yeah also like
keeping a mental note you know like you
find it in the sediment or you find it
in the
you know like it's a it's a really
nice experience to just go out and
sample all the time because sometimes
you
you will find stuff and sometimes you
won't and then you can just remember
where you find stuff and you can just go
back to that place instead of just
looking for you know for the tardigrades
in some other places so
yeah it just just keeps sampling yeah i
definitely have found
in my limited beginnings and into this
that sometimes i'm like well this is
going to be great but then it's like oh
that's all just
filamentous algae like that's all i got
just a lot of
algae filaments and
there's other stuff in there but it
seems like you have such great
uh cultures of
just wild amounts of various things but
no i don't i just sample more than you
that's that's why
[Laughter]
so i believe that's the best only reason
it's um
i think that's what people i think often
don't understand uh when
when they might watch the channel is how
many hours of work james is putting in
behind the scenes into not only
collecting samples but also
how many hours a day he's sitting at his
microscope to
like look through those temples and get
the footage that you see like you might
watch eight minutes of footage a week
but that was like 60 hours of work
on james's end i wish it was 60 hours
some of the episodes we made it's like
they're like
you know for four years i'm sampling and
we just want them just once you know so
it's like
years of work and it's just like um
the key is just sampling so just go out
and simple
and yeah and it's like i do it really
quickly actually i
get this rental scooters you know the
city scooters you just rent with your
lap and and and and then just zoom
to the places where i often sample you
know and i collect samples and i come
back home in like
30 minutes with like i don't know 20
liters of sample
so it's just
like more than me
[Laughter]
uh yeah we have the home sampling and
microscopy
uh hank do you have any updates on the
kickstarter microscope
to provide um i'm we don't have a
hard uh arrival time yet but we do
we it has left china which is the
the hardest part um so we we got them
and it is it was a process uh i think
that ultimately we actually got pretty
lucky
because we got in under a
another sort of bottleneck and change
that happened where
if if we hadn't gotten it out uh when we
did
or like within a few days of when we did
it would have been a few more weeks
delayed
so it's out it is i think that it is
arrived at the port of los angeles
but i think that it has not been taken
out of the shipping container yet
so all of that process because of how
backed up global shipping is right now
the the uh everything just take is
taking extra time so like
getting the container off of the ship
takes extra time getting the ship into
poor fix extra time getting the
microscopes out of the container
onto a train or a truck to get here um
so it's it is moving along and like
uh we our our um our window for when
it's happening is narrowing to the point
where like we have a much better idea of
when things are actually going to arrive
but i don't don't have like a time when
i'm like and also we
ha like one of the things we want to do
is like know how long it's going to take
us to actually physically because we've
never shipped out
something like this before physically
get the things packed packaged up and
and
mail them out to everybody because it's
probably it's like they're not all going
to go out the same day
um if you're gonna be spread over a
couple of weeks probably
but it's looking good uh and i'm
just glad to know that it's
in america uh so it's exciting
yeah and i know that like that like you
just said there's like multiple pieces
to this thing that have to arrive at the
warehouse and they have to be assembled
so yeah it's like
yeah and we've got your pieces already
um it's the microscope itself that is
the
the last piece of the puzzle yeah and
for those asking about like the extra
things like the field guide and the
filters and that stuff that will come
like with your package like you will
receive the field guide
when you receive your microscope uh and
for those asking about like
what what's this kickstarter what did i
why did i not hear about this how do i
get a microscope
that will come later after everyone else
has gotten their microscopes
exactly we'll figure out ways to get
other people microscopes
yeah but i think uh they can they can
subscribe to the
emailing list right now right uh
microcosm maybe yes that's i believe you
are
yes i believe you are accurate and that
if you go to uh
microcosmos.store
i don't know that anything has gone out
there yet because obviously as hank just
said like this is a slow going process
right now
um and we don't know when that store
will will be a thing
uh but if you go there you can put in
your email address at microcosmos.store
and you'll get alerted to when
microscopes become available to the
public but obviously
number one focus is getting them out to
the kickstarter supporters
yeah priscilla just asked if you could
buy the field guide on its own
i would encourage you to because it's
excellent
uh you can't right now but you will be
able to in the future um it was super
helpful
to me um i didn't have it as a physical
thing just as a pdf or a google doc
actually but
um yeah it was super super helpful in my
first venturing into the field
yeah and i think our plan is as of right
now to make most of that stuff available
through the
the store so like the things that were
available through the kickstarter
should be available in some form uh
later on through the store
but again if you want to sign up at the
microcosmos store mailing list
that's how you'll be the first person to
find out and if you're one of the
kickstarter backers
um you'll receive your updates through
the kickstarter update
feature so look at your inbox for those
updates
on shipping and things um
i've got a couple of things from the
chat inc
uh incotanyi says i'm glad and i caught
you guys
i'm watching from rwanda so people are
all over the world watching right now
uh we've also got a question from uh l
dewey who asks are those paramecia
what are those uh these are blepharisma
they're of course
yeah how could you not know
actually how we met right it's like um
hang hang to watch my bloopers my video
and then
uh we started the channel because
one of these had to be sacrificed for
our channel to begin
yeah one of them exploded
not sure why but then we don't know yeah
we uh
which all the channel grew out of that
one blepharizma dying
thank you for your sacrifice yeah
um cool uh yeah i just wanted to
uh mention some more little promo things
real quick
uh if you're not a patreon supporter
already uh you can do that at
patreon.com
donate to micro that's what helps the
channel exist
that's what you know pays the bills
keeps the lights on
uh for those that don't know out of
patreon
you can pay there's two different tiers
we have a two dollar an eight dollar
tier and you get different rewards with
that
with the two dollar tier um you'll get
our
uh like the
uncut that's the word i was looking for
our uncut footage uh
montage video that we put out once a
month um which is essentially like a
collection of footage
over four or five videos that's like an
hour long with just music
no narration you can just put it on the
background and zen out
um and then you also will get if you're
signed up at the eight dollar level
you'll get your name in the end credits
and you'll also get the weekly
high-res wallpapers that you can use on
your phone or your desktop or wherever
you want to use them
uh and also you get access to our
discord where people hang out and share
their own microscopy or just ask
questions about the channel and stuff
and you can get that at any level any
dollar amount you donate you get access
to the discord
so yeah thank you to all of you uh who
support us on patreon
we literally could not do it without you
jay
yes um i'm we're we're so
lucky to have uh to have patronage
and uh so all of our supporters
uh all the people who don't who don't
who aren't able to support they're the
reason that this thing exists
so i'm uh
really happy to have everybody on board
uh james what was that dot that's
covered in bacteria
uh that's a there's an algae called
uh trejelo monas okay so
it shouldn't be there but i don't know
how it
got in there
so it's just like enjoying the
microscope light because they're
photosynthetic
and they have um they have tiny
shells around their like their cell
and that shell usually like at the
beginning it's transparent
but because the um some
some uh compounds just seep into the
shell and it makes it brown in time like
iron
or manganese it just it changes the
color
of the cell also we are seeing right now
oh yeah
the bacteria is attracted to it because
it's probably releasing some sugar
through photosynthesis
because the photosynthetic organisms
they reduce sugar or
and um might be because of the oxygen
because uh
under the under recovers cover slip it's
the
oxygen content might be less than around
the
photosynthetic organism and so bacteria
just finding the optimal
you know like um most preferred place
to just live so they're
getting concentrated around the
photosynthetic organism
there's just the directions sorry you go
uh the edge that everything's bouncing
off of it's at the edge of the cover
slip
uh that's that's uh petroleum jelly
so what i do for these um slides because
i
try to keep them for longer time so i
put like a
petroleum jelly on the corners
and i put them in the humidity chambers
so
like in the humidity chamber it loses
some of the
water so the slide gets like um
thinner you know and it might crush the
microorganisms
so i'm putting this um petroleum jelly
so it's just like
um supporting the way of the cover slip
and they're surviving for a long time so
this this slide i think one week old so
i put these things one week ago
here and
we have the oops we have the petroleum
jelly
here just going to catch up in a second
[Music]
so yeah i was a bit generous
here because i didn't want to kill the
bill of
so it's a really really big you know
puncher yeah
yeah somebody was asking about that in
the comments about uh basically
you said you've collected these things a
week or two days ago whatever like that
and how
how are you keeping them alive for those
multiple days and
yeah it seems like petroleum jelly and
humidity chamber is the good combo there
yeah but i i have like um like a liter
of them
in my bathroom so also
yeah do you ever have people come over
that don't really know what's going on
and they walk in they're like what's
with all the jars buddy
oh nobody comes to my house so i'm just
saying
[Laughter]
some people just joined the chat you
know just now i didn't get
that yeah
yeah i have uh soil samples i have i
think
60 bottles like stuck on top of
each other in my bathroom as well so
it's like
that would be a really weird thing to
see i think if you go to somebody's
dirt yeah
before they know what you do for a
living okay
yeah yeah
so we've got a question from katie kelly
who is a patron
who asks um what's the sort of minimum
equipment
a novice would need to dip their toes
into microscopy
also what degree of magnification
qualifies as microscopic
that's a good question i don't think
that there is an official line
yeah but the standard microscopes come
with you know like with magnification
from 40x to 1000x
so and uh
the microscope as oops something is
drying up oh that doesn't look good
so um so just couple of hundred dollars
would be
enough to start as we started on our
channel i think
uh because we made the first three
episode of our channel with a 160 dollar
microscope that i
build up from unbranded
microscope pieces like
and yeah so you
but it increases like the cost increases
uh with i don't know how to say it
like nicely but it's like this
microscope doesn't cost
three hundred dollars so yeah it's
almost it seems at times exponential
like the way yeah i will talk to james
about things where
uh somebody asked in the chat actually
like how do we get our upgrades and the
answer is
money like paying for them yeah yeah so
that's where like
obviously part of the the patreon money
and the
revenue from the channel and all this
stuff like it goes towards those things
because yes they the the price goes up
very dramatically the moment you want to
take like what might seem to some people
on the outside like a small
step up in quality uh it is actually
a huge step up as far as the technology
goes or objective lenses goes and
especially as far as the price goes
yeah yeah so like a couple of weeks ago
i made a graph
of the pens i owe
versus the microscope upgrades i got so
like over the years i got like two pairs
of pens
but like my my
microscope upgrade is like
um i think like 100 times more expensive
that i
like how i started who needs who needs
more than two pairs of pants though
yes
um you can also like there are now super
inexpensive usb micro microscopes
they they are different kind of the so
there's microscopes that shine light
through the sample
and that's the way that microscopy is
traditionally done and then there
aren't you know just things that like
take very high
resolution magnified pictures basically
um of like the i don't know what it's
called
james i'm sure knows what it's called
when the light is shining down instead
of through
uh reflected light yeah yeah
um and you can get those now they're
gonna be not great
um they're like the federal glasses
honestly
yeah yeah and they are they're like
i enjoy using mine for like watching
ladybugs eat aphids
and like it's more of a like you can get
like good view of insects that you
otherwise can't get a good view of
um but i have and and also like i just
love to look at
like pants and stuff and be like wow
stuff stuff's made of stuff i you don't
you don't really notice
uh until you look really close um you
gotta take a closer look at that one of
your uh two pairs of pants
yeah i don't wanna wait to write a
script about
pant one and then pant two
very limited sample size
i got a quick lightning round question
for everybody uh
what is your favorite microbe and why
um also i got um um
thunderstorm alert today so it's like
things going wild just i'm sorry about
it
yeah does anyone have a favorite microbe
amoebas
which is kind of cheating because
there's a lot of amoebas
it's also not even all related to each
other nope
yeah but anytime we have a script about
an episode coming up about amoebas i go
in thinking okay
this will be whatever their amoebas and
then like halfway through i'm like this
is the most fun thing to write about
just something squishy right yeah yeah
there's so many ways to just be a blob
well especially when we get like super
up close with amoebas and you're trying
to understand how they move
and you just see all the little like
particles inside of them moving
into a new like leg that didn't exist a
second ago and you're just like
so pretty yeah my brain can't really
understand
what exactly and how this is doing this
thing but it's yes
nobody's not so it's like yeah
it's okay i uh there's a reason that
things are compared to them when they
are confusing
yep i like i like a rotifer
i love i love them i love watching them
run around and then they find a nice
spot and then they just sit there and
consume
i like that you can see they're like
they kind of have jaws
like very early like
mashers in their throats to squish some
stuff up which i think is amazing
especially
[Laughter]
yeah sorry my cat's throwing a hissy fit
right now
it's hard that's i mean james isn't
going to pick a favorite microbe there's
no way
yeah i i love like a mario lore and i
also love
powder great so yeah
like sometimes like when we're i'm
editing those videos i just want to
leave like
a three minute long clip of one hydra
just like slowly moving and i'm like
this is like i think very interesting
but there are
some people who might not want just
three minutes of the same clip
yeah what uh why was there a sudden
current on your slide just then
what is happening because some some part
of the slide
is getting dry so it's just like the
water is just
you know just moving slightly
and do you just you just add more water
to keep it on
yeah i have to now i have to otherwise
yeah
these bluffers are not gonna see another
daylight you know
oh that's such a cute cat noise
it's cute because you're not the one
getting yelled at
[Laughter]
there are some people asking about like
oh go ahead
i was gonna say also the gastrocs are
also great to look at
oh yeah i love
i think especially with our more recent
microscope upgrades like even the
tardigrade
stuff like when you're looking at these
things in like the thousand x
magnification and you're seeing
the texture of the thing that you
wouldn't
necessarily expect or normally see when
like we did a recent
uh clip of a tardigrade at 1000 x where
you can see like just little like divots
in it like a little like skin
texture essentially going on that like
yeah you don't when you think of a
tardigrade you're not
just like thinking of these like little
like poor like structures all along
their skin
and i think it's the same with gastro
tricks where people have an idea of what
a microbe is in their mind and they see
a gastro trick and they're like
what is what is this weird spiky dragon
thing
maybe we can make an episode about them
at 1000x i think it would look really
cool
[Music]
also like i'm making some videos about
their
x development so it takes a couple of
hours for the eggs to
develop and uh maybe we can just watch
some
cute little baby dragons just you know
hatching
yeah yeah i mean that sounds amazing
just there i think we have our title
already
maybe dragon's hatching boom yep uh
[Music]
yeah i think i also wanted to sort of
like tease some upcoming videos we have
coming down the pipeline
for people so that you kind of know what
to expect coming up uh
something doesn't matter to most people
but we have season breaks that happen
uh in microcosmos every six months
there's a season
it just kind of it doesn't really affect
your viewing we take maybe a week or two
off in between but
uh it's just for more planning processes
than anything
uh but our season four finale is coming
up and we'll be talking about some uh
suctorian parasites that are super cool
and we've also got a starlet sea anemone
video coming coming up uh and then in
the next week's video is a hematococcus
video
about these little red blood berries and
how uh when they get stressed out
they turn red and curl up into a ball
because life is hard
and they are coming from a cemetery yeah
right
yeah yeah from a bird bath in a cemetery
respect a very specific location yes yes
graves were disturbed for this video
uh but yeah we have a couple other fun
videos coming up in season five which i
said starts on
august 30th uh we've got the fungus mold
one coming up
we've got some uh i don't want to give
away everything but we're gonna dive
into the world of light a little bit
more and sort of like our new microscopy
techniques
and not only what they let us see but
also the effect that they have
on the microbes that we are looking at
uh which can sometimes be
quite negative uh we're gonna dive
deeper into
the the intricacies of bat and
we'll see more blepharism in that
episode yes
sorry to the is my feature in that
episode yeah
they're not gonna be happy but it's you
know
sometimes you gotta do what you gotta do
uh so yeah we only have a few minutes
here left before we wrap up these things
fly
by uh so i wanted to just kind of kind
of
go around uh and see i guess one of the
questions we got was
uh asking if what is what we have what
haven't we talked about on the channel
yet that you
wish we could talk about or you're
hoping that we still can talk about in
the future
um panspermia
okay i mean the thing about the
the thing about tardigrades is that
they're everywhere
and i asked this question to james and i
was like how that how in the world are
tardigrades everywhere
and he's like well they just they just
turn into spores and blow around and so
like there's a certain
size at which things get too big to be
everywhere
but like below a certain size they can
just they just like get picked up by the
wind and blown across oceans
and and then you can have a species that
is like literally
the same species everywhere on earth
which seems very
like sort of counter to my understanding
of evolutionary biology um
i think it's like under one milliliter
millimeter
um size it just because
uh we made an episode about this already
it's like everything is everywhere but
the environment selects so if
if organisms are under one milli milli
millimeter uh they disperse all over the
world
but with tardigrades it's um there are
some
reports i think it was iceland like in
um uh tardigrades
bur in snow so they were like snowing
so you get tardigrades right they were
in the south
yeah in the snow and after a snow storm
you just you know you get tardigrades
everywhere because they were like
wind blow them up in the atmosphere and
they
they were just you know dispersed like
hundreds of kilometers
and then they just you know smoked all
over
the car they're just in the they're in
the sky there's targets in the sky
and we'll probably be talking about that
we have a uh a small tease i'm not gonna
give away everything we have a video
coming up that uh sort of talks about
tardigrades uh in this way of them being
in antarctica
uh and how like you can find the same
target grades in antarctica that you can
find in
poland or montana um and so we'll be
diving into that
idea a little bit more in season five as
well uh for me
i think one of the things that i still
keep trying to make happen and one day
we will make it happen
is to talk more about the research done
on the iss
um with roofers and tardigrades and all
this stuff they just recently had a big
rotifer experiment going on up on the
iss
um and yes they don't obviously
they're not out there trying to capture
beautiful footage to make youtube videos
so they're not as worried about like
the cinematography of their stuff it's
lots of stills and lots of things like
that so
there's not a lot of footage available
publicly yeah of these things but i
would love to do a video that is
talking about space yeah i i have a
better idea let's just
send some tardigrades to space like oh
you're going to say
space
i think it's a great crowdfunding idea
you know let's just
get like one million subscribers let's
just send some tardigrades to outer
space and
they're not very heavy it can't take
that much energy right
[Music]
let's just get a big old weather balloon
and tie some tardigrades to it boom
we're done all right well
we need to wrap up here uh so before we
go
uh i will quickly do the promo stuff
again we have the new tardigrade t-shirt
available at dftba.com available in ash
and dark teal
and whichever one doesn't sell as well
over the next month will go away forever
uh we have the patreon which is
patreon.com journey2micro
uh where you can support the channel and
also
james's book the hidden beauty of the
microscopic world you should go check
that out as well
um but yeah anything uh anybody have
anything else to say before we
log off here ah thank you to everybody
who's hanging out
and thank you to all of our patrons on
patreon who
who make it so that we can do this very
cool thing
and thank you to blepharism as well and
thank you
everyone who sent in their questions
sorry we can't get to all of the
questions uh
we just didn't have that much time we
got more than we expected i think
uh thank you to paula who's uh running
this whole thing behind the scenes
um and uh yeah tweet
voting thank you uh no
thank you guys for joining us it's a lot
of fun all right
well yeah thank you everyone bye